Is there a point when taking HCl and digestive enzymes that you would say one could be taking
too much? Oh, for sure. Not so much digestive enzymes. You can't really overdose digestive enzymes.
The more you take, you know, you'll initially digestive enzymes that you take with your food,
you're going to use, your body's going to use to help digest that food.
If you take too many digestive enzymes with your meal, you could have some loose stools maybe,
but you will absorb some of those that you don't need in your digestive tract. That's a whole idea
of enzyme therapy for cancer. You're taking very, very, very high dose digestive enzymes
away from food on an empty stomach and you're absorbing them in the hope that they'll circulate
and then they'll help break down the waist layer around the cancer. So you can't really
od digestive enzymes, but you certainly can od hydrochloric acid. So hydrochloric acid is taken to
supplement the lack of hydrochloric acid production in your stomach and even a small amount could be
too much when you start, because if you have a lack of hydrochloric acid in your stomach,
you could get a buildup and overgrowth of H. Pylori and then destruction of the stomach wall
and a small little ulcer. Doesn't have to be a screaming bleeding ulcer, but you can have a small
little ulcer and then you take HCl with digestive enzymes because you hear those are good for you
or Dr. Cutters told you to and boy, they cause a lot of pain when I take them. Even when I take one,
it just kills my stomach. Well, that means you probably have an ulcer. You got to back off of that
you have to go on like the GI soothe product, a product that will be healing to the gut that has
deglycerized licorice and slippery elm and some other herbs in it that will heal that stomach wall.
For a sore period of time, then you could either go back on the HCl or try a little bit lighter
acid which would be acetic acid in like apple cider vinegar. But let's say that the HCl doesn't
cause your stomach to have issues, but I just want the best digestion. So what would be too much
for me? Well, you could titrate up in your HCl and digestive enzymes and compound product until you
do get a little tummy aches with, I've had people go up to 678 per meal and typically you do not want
to stay on that type of high dosage and then when they feel like they're starting to get better digestion,
they'll titrate down to 65432 with each meal and you play with your dosage like that. Certainly,
you need more if you're dependent on what you eat. So I know for most people it's they're going to eat
a lot of meat. Let's say they're going to eat a steak that is not as pre-digested as hamburger.
Let's say that you might feel better, less bloated, have better digestion if you took baby two or three
of them. But if you're eating just a smoothie, you might take none or if you're eating some a smaller meal
with less difficult to digest food, then you'd maybe only take one. So you learn to play with your
dosage, but yes, you can take too much HDL.